et une coque 26 marquée par le retour
des états unis à la table des
discussions dont washington qui à
nouveau rejoint les corps de paris après
un retrait de donald trump son
successeur joe biden veut lui prendre
une autre direction le président
américain doit annoncer d'ailleurs dans
les prochaines minutes une série
d'actions pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique on retrouve
notre correspondant thomas bonnin en
direct de washington
bonsoir thomas joe biden qui va donc
reprendre à la parole de manière
imminente puisqu'il a déjà parlé hier il
avait d'ailleurs déjà promis beaucoup de
choses à son arrivée à la maison blanche
pour quel résultat pour le moment en
tout cas
et bien c'est peu de concret finalement
dans les propositions et dans les
actions entreprises par joe biden depuis
qu'il est arrivé à la maison blanche on
sait que c'était un thème de campagne
très important pour le candidat
démocrate à l'époque puisque cela le
différencier de façon assez notable de
donald trump qui avaient des positions
très différentes sur le climat aura donc
eu beaucoup de promesses de la part de
joe biden sur la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
je vous propose d'écouter justement
cette opposition de style entre le
candidat joe biden et le candidat donald
trump c'était donc au mois de septembre
joe biden n'est pas un ami de la
pennsylvanie il est d'ailleurs pour les
raisons qu'on vient d'évoquer votre pire
cauchemar by john a soutenu chacune des
attaques mondialistes sur les
travailleurs de la pennsylvanie l'accord
de libre échange nord américain l'entrée
de la chine dans l'organisation mondiale
du commerce qui a permis à la chine de
devenir une puissance l'accord de
partenariat transpacifique la corée
l'accord horrible et ridicule de paris
sur le climat qui a privé notre nation
de son énergie et le soi-disant clean
power plein si on donne un pyromane du
climat quatre années de plus à la maison
blanche comment pourrait-on s'étonner
que l'amérique s'embrase encore
davantage si nous donnons un climato
sceptiques quatre ans de plus à la
maison blanche comment pourrait-on
s'étonner que plus de régions d'amérique
soit sous l'eau on va donc pour les
positions radicalement opposées deux
anciens candidats à la présidence elle
est d'ailleurs lorsque joe biden est
arrivé à la maison blanche l'une de ses
premières mesures a donc été de
réintégrer l'accord de paris sur le
climat est un acte plutôt symbolique
suivie de la présentation d'un plan
d'investissement d'envergure pour là
encore lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
un plan qui a été revue et corrigée
depuis parce qu'on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de blocage au congrès l'a
encore été modifiées est la semaine
dernière et joe biden aurait sans doute
espéré que ce plan soit adopté au
congrès avant qu'ils ne se rendent à la
coop 26 à glasgow mais ce n'est donc
toujours pas le cas les négociations
vont toujours bon train au sein du
congrès américain avec encore des
discussions et des négociations qui se
déroulent à l'heure où je vous parle
alors malgré tout joe biden veut se
positionner à la pointe de ce combat
contre le réchauffement climatique sur
la scène internationale au mois de
septembre dernier déjà il y avait une
réunion virtuelle
en amont de cette coop 26 et joe biden
avait appelé les dirigeants du monde
entier à prendre la mesure des enjeux se
servant alors des différentes
catastrophes naturelles qui se sont
déroulées ces derniers mois et coûté au
cours des deux dernières semaines j'ai
voyagé à travers les états unis et j'ai
pu constater les dégâts et les
destructions causées par les ouragans
les inondations et les feux de forêt la
chine continue à travers excusez moi le
climat continue à changer à travers
l'europe l'afrique et l'amérique latine
vous avez enduré des inondations
massives des incendies ont fait rage en
australie en amazonie et dans la toundra
russian
et c'est donc là toute l'ambivalence de
la position de joe biden comment peut-il
convaincre à l'international alors
qu'ils peinent déjà à rassembler dans
son propre camp sur ces questions là aux
états unis certains dénoncent aussi une
forme d'hypocrisie entre les paroles et
les actes du président américain puisque
rien que dimanche dernier il a notamment
appelé à augmenter la production
mondiale de pétrole en soulignant lui
même le caractère ironique de sa
déclaration mais en rappelant qu' à
l'heure actuelle les pays du monde
entier étaient encore tributaire des
énergies fossiles beaucoup soulignent
aussi le cortège de 10 zen de voitures
qui accompagne le déplacement du
président américain et ce y compris lors
d'un sommet pour le climat comme c'est
le cas de la coop 26 à glasgow et puis
parce que les images sont aussi plus
forte que certains un discours beaucoup
ont partagé la photo et les images de
joe biden assoupis pendant un discours
lors de cette coque 26 une image qui a
finalement plus circuler que les propos
du président américain